this video is brought to you by squarespace from
websites and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and run your
business check out squarespace through the link
in the description below more on them in a bit
it was a night out of some gothic horror in june
of 1816 a terrific storm erupted over lake geneva
lightning flashed across dark water thunder
boomed in a bedroom in the villa dia deity
a 19 year old girl lay awake transfixed by a
disturbing vision i saw the hideous phantasm
of a man stretched out she would like to say
and then on the working of some powerful engine
show signs of life it was a half glimpse of a
nightmare one most of us would have probably
tried to shake off as a sign that would have
too much cheese and fine port before bed but
that teenage girl wasn't most of us she was mary
wollenstonecraft godwin the future mary shelley
and that vision would become the basis for
one of the 19th century's greatest novels
frankenstein a pioneering classic of sci-fi
and horror frankenstein today remains one of
the most influential books ever written yet how
much do most of us know about the woman behind it
born of famous parents connected to the
romantic poets mary shelley's life from
the outside appeared charmed yet it was also
a life lived in the shadow of immense tragedy
fittingly for someone who'd write a classic work
of gothic horror mary shelley was born shortly
before the stroke of midnight on august 30th 1797.
of course she wasn't born mary shelley although
we're going to keep using her married name in
these early sections since it's the one that
everyone knows but rather mary wallston craft
godwin a frankenstein version of her parents
names william godwin and mary wollstonecraft it
was a name that would give her a lot to live up
to both william and mary were radicals who were
as famous as they were financially unstable the
political philosopher william godwin was an early
proponent of anarchism and a leading writer on
social issues if anything mary wollstonecraft was
even more impressive the author of the vindication
of the rights of women she lived and breathed
feminism at a time when men mostly saw women as
pretty baby-making machines sadly for mary
shelley though she'd never get to meet this
one-woman powerhouse two hours after her birth
it became clear the afterburst hadn't come away
william godwin went to find help and at 3am
he returned with the physician louis poynyand
unfortunately poignant was a product of his time
a doctor who thought washing his hands before
touching a patient was as absurd as operating
while wearing lederhosen poignant removed the
traces of afterbirth with dirty fingers this led
to serious infection and mary wollstonecraft died
of septicemia just 11 days later and no we can't
think of a better metaphor for the backwardness of
gender relations in this era than an intelligent
woman literally being killed by an underqualified
and overconfident man the death of her mother when
she was just a few days old left a hole in mary
shelley's young life that would never be filled
not that william didn't try in 1801 he married
mary jane claremont who'd soon become famous
publishing children's books it was a union that
swelled the family to a ridiculous size alongside
shelly the younger generation now consisted of a
half-sister fanny claremont's children claire and
charles and would soon also include a brand new
baby but while shelley and her stepsister claire
claremont became close friends the same could be
said of her stepmom as far as young shelley was
concerned mary jane claremont was evil incarnate
like if some mad scientist had managed to
cross breed the wicked witch of the west with
diobrando by all accounts this was hugely unfair
mary jane tried to be a good substitute mother
even helping shelley put out her first book at age
eleven the children's tale mancia nong tong poor
but shelley wasn't having these kind gestures this
woman had replaced her dead mother that was all
she needed to hate her still for all its drama
shelley's childhood was enriching in ways that
were hyper unusual for the era actually scratch
that for any era really while plagued by debt
and forever teetering on the brink of bankruptcy
william godwin was still lionized in intellectual
circles this meant his children were taken to
see lectures from leading thinkers it meant
home visits from admirers like samuel taylor
coolridge it also meant being encouraged to
better themselves by spending each morning deep
in study by learning languages shelly herself
became fluent in latin greek french and italian
by the summer of 1812 then mary shelley was 14
hyper-intelligent extremely well-read and able
to run intellectual circles around most adults
she could also be hell to deal with that june she
was packed off to stay with friends in scotland
for two years ostensibly for her health but
more likely because she and mary jane were on
the verge of killing one another still the move
wasn't permanent she could pop down to london on
visits it would be on one of these visits that
she would meet the man who'd transform her life
the fact mary shelley ever met her husband
was down to sheer dumb luck the son of an
aristocratic family percy shelley was 20 already
married and had a child on the way but he was also
a radical atheist who'd recently been disowned
by his dad sir timothy and was now hunting for
a surrogate father the man he'd landed on well
his political hero william godwin mary shelley
was just 15 when the poet came blowing through
the family's life like a breath of fresh air
zephyr from a distant land the teenage girl was
very interested in exploring but it wouldn't be
until she turned 16 and returned permanently
from scotland in spring of 1814 that their
romance really began at first it was more an
over-romanticized courtship the pair sought out
her mother's grave where they would sit together
and read her works but at some point it clearly
became more than just a two-person study group
so much so that william godwin tried to forbid
shelley from ever seeing percy instead she ran
away with him on july 28 1814 by the faint light
of dawn mary and her stepsister claire clement
snuck out of the family home and into a waiting
carriage then the two of them set off with percy
for the adventure of a lifetime for six weeks that
summer the trio toured europe still shattered
by the napoleonic wars they saw france germany
switzerland a great romantic tool that would later
inspire mary shelley's first adult book history
of a six-week tour at last that september shelly
returned to england penniless pregnant and firmly
in love only to find her family super unimpressed
william godwin might have been a radical but that
radicalism didn't extend to some poet prancing in
and sweeping his teenage daughter off to europe
shunned by their relatives suddenly at the heart
of a juicy society scandal shelly and percy moved
in together to try and make a go of it since
percy was an advocate of free love this included
odd stuff like shelly unenthusiastically having
an affair with his friend thomas jefferson hogg
it also included unimaginable tragedy in february
of 1815 mary shelley gave birth to her first
daughter prematurely 11 days later she came in to
wake the baby in the night for feeding but saw it
was sleeping so deeply that she left it in peace
the next morning her yet unnamed daughter was dead
it was a heartbreaking moment in the couple's new
relationship one perhaps best encapsulated by an
entry in shelley's diary dream that my little baby
came to life again that it had only been cold and
that we rubbed it before the fire and it lived she
wrote awake and find no baby and just a warning if
you're already feeling rather depressed children
dying is going to be a constant miserable theme of
this episode if you want a happy story well look
elsewhere only weeks after the nameless child died
shelley felt pregnant again this time the baby
would survive long enough to get a name william
but while william would stick around for a couple
more chapters please don't get too attached to him
come spring of 1816 the couple were bruised by
tragedy and fed up with still being the object
of a scandal finally in may they seem to have
decided you know what to hell with this judgmental
rainy island again joined by claire claremont
they once again set out for europe this time
in the direction of italy but first they'd make a
detour clairemonsi had other reasons for heading
to europe just recently she'd conducted an affair
with the brooding dashing lord byron and was
desperate to see more of him it would be thanks to
her pushing that the shelley's changed direction
heading instead for the shores of lake geneva and
the waiting scandalous poet there the four of them
were destined to make literary history now just
before we get into the rest of today's video let
me tell you about our glorious sponsor squarespace
this is the age of creation think about it people
are online making stuff all the time people
making youtube channels podcasts websites even
online stores you've either got a great idea
yourself or you probably know someone who does
and when it's time to move that project from your
head to the screen in front of you that's where
squarespace comes in it's the perfect web tool to
help you fashion the internet into whatever you
want it to be maybe the hands-on site with lots of
opinions and ideas about what exactly your website
should look like if so very cool squarespace gives
you all of the customization options you could
ever want with no updates no patches no technical
nonsense to worry about or maybe you just need
something functional something that works with
minimal thought so you can stay focused on the
content and not the code of paint just use one
of their quick and beautiful templates to make
a website that's both fresh and simple once you're
done setting up your website locking in the domain
maybe playing with some of the colors there are
so many extra features that squarespace provides
that your website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portals social integrations member only
areas analytics commercial options 20 customer
support everything you need really is in one
place so when you're ready to get started on the
next project of yours big or small if it involves
a website it's got to be with squarespace right
now you can go to squarespace.com for a free trial
when you're ready to launch your new site go to
squarespace.com biographics to save ten percent
off your first purchase of a website or a
domain and let's get back to today's video
in the spring of 1815 mount tambora in modern-day
indonesia detonated like an angry bomb insane
amounts of gases were spewed into the atmosphere a
sulfur veil that enveloped the planet lowering the
temperature of the northern hemisphere by around 4
degrees this was such a sharp drop that 1816 would
become the year without summer that year rivers
froze in august floods swept europe there was
record rainfall in geneva that meant shelley
percy byron and clement spent their spare time not
boating and hiking and thinking sublime thoughts
but stuck inside staring out at the rain try not
to go mad from the moment the trio had hooked
up with byron and his personal physician john
polidori they'd gotten along like an indonesian
volcano on fire moving into neighboring homes but
as the weather turned and they began spending more
time cooped up in byron's villa died daddy that
friendship had curdled into unbearable tension
polidori was trying to get into mary shelley's
pants while claremon was trying to get into
byron's while byron was doing his utmost to stop
that from happening as the tension grew it became
clear that the group was on the verge of everybody
either shooting one another or starting a gigantic
and insanely regrettable orgy so lord byron
decided to occupy them with a bit of a challenge
everyone at his villa would have to write a ghost
story for some this was easy john polidori
got right to work on the tale of a seductive
aristocratic vampire that was essentially an
extended satire on byron himself but mary shelley
had hit a brick wall for days she was forced to
confess each morning that her muse had evidently
carried on to italy without her with each day
her frustration and embarrassment grew then
one evening it happened shelley was lying awake in
bed listening to the tambora caused storms howling
over the lake her mind was filled with thoughts of
a discussion byron and percy had been drawn into a
few nights earlier on the then red-hot science of
galvanism this was the theory that human corpses
could be reanimated with electricity this is where
we first met mary shelley in our introduction
today waiting on the gods of writing to send
her a spark instead they sent her an inferno the
vision shelley saw of an engine bringing a dead
man to life set her mind racing come mourning
she had the germ of something a story about a
hubristic scientist who creates new life only
to abandon it driving it to murder a story that
would go down in history as frankenstein one of
the english language's earliest works of science
fiction frankenstein is at once both a deceptively
simple fable and a deeply laid work within its
gothic pages people have seen an allegory of the
french revolution and the forces it unleashed
a meditation on the advances of the industrial
age even a veiled commentary on slavery the fight
for abolition in britain's colonies being one of
shelly's passions perhaps more importantly though
it's simply a cracking read over 200 years later
shelley's story still holds up as well as the day
it was written on publication in 1818 it was a
sensation one friend wrote percy that the novel
seemed to be universally known and read while
critics were divided between those who thought
it powerful and those who thought it unseemly
readers just couldn't get enough of it the only
annoying thing must have been the assumptions that
some of them made since shelley had published the
book anonymously and since percy had written the
forward and since this was the good old sexist
past everyone was like let's just assume that
percy shelley wrote this i mean there's no
way anyone with a vagina could have created
frankenstein am i right it wasn't until the second
edition in 1823 that mary shelley would finally
get the public credit she deserved by then though
her young life would have been consumed by loss
it was the 29th of august 1816 when shelley percy
and claire returned to england mary carrying the
idea for frankenstein claire carrying byron's
baby but rather than a triumphant homecoming
it was the beginning of a series of misfortunes
that would soon come to plague shelley the first
took place that autumn on october the 9th shelley
lost her half-sister fanny to suicide exactly one
month later percy's wife harriet threw herself
into the thames while pregnant with his child her
body was only found on december 10th but while
percy may have felt some dark sense of guilt he
also didn't look a gift horse in the mouth barry
and percy shelley were officially wed just 20
days after harriet's waterlogged remains were
pulled from the river a real too soon moment if
there ever was one still the marriage started
well enough now her relationship with percy
was official william godwin reconnected with his
daughter just five months later shelley finished
frankenstein that same year 1817 her daughter
clara was born giving the shelley's hope that
their first lost baby had been an unhappy one-off
but no this is the life of mary shelley remember
one we've already warned you is filled with
endless agonizing sadness even as the publication
of frankenstein approached she was going to have
to deal with more misery in spring of 1818 the
couple returned with claire to europe hoping to
reconnect with byron in italy and introduce him
to his new child at first things were great the
group found it liberating to be out of stuffy old
england back in europe where they felt they could
be free but the trip quickly soured in venice that
september baby clara caught dysentery and died
having just turned one year old the shelley's
grief was vast unnameable it was also only the
beginning the following year in rome their son
william was carried away by malaria aged just
three the deaths of her two surviving children
in such quick succession broke mary shelley she
withdrew into herself her relationship with percy
crumbling in her diary she wrote the despairing
phrase this is the journal book of misfortunes
honestly that was an understatement mary shelley
may have only been 22 and already the mother of
three dead kids but her future was filled with yet
more tragedy still there was the odd ray of light
when william died shelley was already pregnant
again in november 1819 she gave birth to percy
florence shelly his middle name taken from the
italian city where he was staying and just to stop
you from worrying fear not unlike his siblings
percy florence actually survives into adulthood
in fact the boy's birth heralded a brief period of
calm as frankenstein became a sensation home mary
and percy settled with their son in pisa there
they made international friends and briefly lived
the lives that they'd always dreamed of ordinary
lives not haunted by the specter of death watching
their child grow in the life of mary shelley this
time was an oasis a little pool of happiness amid
a dark desert of grief so let's just give her a
moment to enjoy it shall we before we get back
to all of the horrid stuff a short break between
chapters where for the briefest of seconds we can
let our heroine be happy because when we
come back things are only going to get worse
in may of 1822 the shellies and claire arrived
in san terenzo with their friends edward and jane
williams to spend summer on the wild italian coast
from the start the trip was troubled just before
they left the daughter claire had had with byron
died of fever aged just five at the same time mary
and percy's relationship was badly on the rocks
half wrecked by percy's affairs and the other half
by the lingering depression both still felt over
the children's deaths shelley was even pregnant
again but not happily already in a low mood she
couldn't take the wild swings of pregnancy by the
time they arrived at their rented home of carson
magley she was convinced disaster laid just over
the horizon horrible as it is to say she was right
the first tragedy came on june the 16th that day
shelley suffered a horrifying miscarriage one
which saw her lose so much blood it's a miracle
she survived in fact she nearly didn't it was only
by making her sit in an ice bath for hours that
percy managed to stop the bleeding allowing her
to see another day the brutal miscarriage marked
the end of shelley's fifth and last pregnancy
having been pregnant for most of the previous
six years the demands in her body had simply
gotten too great after this there would be no more
attempts at children especially when you consider
what came next while mary shelley's depression had
manifested itself in becoming withdrawn percies
had made itself felt through strange visions
and increasingly erratic behavior not long after
his wife's near fatal miscarriage he and edward
williams took his boat don juan across the gulf
of speezia on july 8 1822 they were warned against
returnings and storms were brewing but percy seems
to have just waved the threat away and then when
a storm did blow up he refused an offer of help
from a passing ship maybe he was just too naive to
realize the danger they were in or maybe losing
his kids had left him with a death wish either
way the don juan was lost in the squall ten days
later percy shelley's waterlogged body was found
by then it had been in the sea for so long that
his face had been eaten away he was identified
by a book of poems in his pocket after a brief
period buried to comply with italian law shelley
had her husband's body dug back up on august 16
his remains were burned on a beach watched over
by two old friends and percy's fellow poet lord
byron supposedly his heart was retrieved from
the ashes which shelly then wrapped in silk and
carried around for the rest of her life the death
of her husband aged 29 was a shock mary shelley
would never recover from for eight years she wrote
i communicated with unlimited freedom with one
whose genius far transcending mind awakened and
guided by thoughts i conversed with him recited
my errors of judgment obtained new lights from him
and my mind was satisfied now i am alone oh how
alone the stars maybe hold my tears and the wind
drink my size but my thoughts are a sealed
treasure which i can confide to none but of course
she wasn't really alone percy florence was still
alive and now she needed to take care of her son
without her husband's income at first shelley
tried to remain in italy in the country her
husband had loved so much soon though the
money ran out percy's father said timothy
coldly informed her he would only support her
son if percy florence was raised in england
so it was that against her will the author of
frankenstein returned to the country of her birth
originally she hoped to publish percy shelley's
collected poems but sir timothy was such a
colossal penis that he threatened to cut her off
if the family name ever appeared in print again
unable to raise a son on her income alone
shelly obeyed waiting for when the awful
old man might die and allow her and her boy to
be free sadly she would wait a very long time
shelley's one consolation back in rainy
conservative england was that frankenstein's
popularity was greater than ever 1823 saw
the first theatrical production a play that
was such a smash hit but there would be six
versions of it that year alone by 1824 the
tale was so well known that the foreign secretary
directly referenced it in a speech to parliament
as shelly riley noted of this period lo and behold
i found myself famous by now though it wasn't just
frankenstein that she was famous for but for
being the last living link to the romantics yep
it's time for yet more characters to die in this
case lord byron who was carried away by illness
while fighting in the greek war of independence
with john polidori already dead by suicide mary
shelley and claire claremont became the last
surviving members of the bright young poets who'd
gathered at lake geneva only eight years
earlier to change literary history or as
shell yourself put it i am the last relic of
a beloved race my companions extinct before me
a quick reminder if you're needed at this stage
she's only 26 26 already widowed with three dead
children and a miscarriage behind her and all her
closest friends long enough to the great villa
diodati in the sky still shelley was at least able
to keep working in 1826 she published the last man
a tale about the lone survivor of a devastating
plague that's now considered her second best work
unfortunately sir timothy hit the roof when he
found out and he briefly cut her off because
apparently that's just how miserable that old [ __
] was after that shelley's art never quite hit the
same heights again now we don't want to give the
impression nothing happened in these later years
while poor by the standards of her class shelley
was still able to travel even meeting the marquis
de lafayette in paris in 1828 like a 19th century
version of one of those marvel cameos despite
sir timothy she still lived in an orthodox life
befriending the writer mary diana dodds who was
romantically involved with another woman and
only ever appeared in public as a male she
even continued writing in 1834 shelley picked
up regular work writing biographical sketches
of famous people for the cabinet cyclopedia a
sort of handheld biographics for old-timey folk
but still in the grand scheme of things these were
the quiet years shawn of the adventure romance and
impact of shelley's early life the flip side of
that though is that they were also stable percy
florence grew up to be a healthy young man free of
the tragedy that bedeviled his long-dead siblings
as the years passed a timothy mellowed at least
allowing shelly to publish a definitive volume of
her dead husband's poems in 1840. better still the
old fart died not long after leaving shelly and
her son enough money to never worry about poverty
again not that shelley had long to enjoy her
newfound wealth mary shelley died of a brain tumor
on the 1st of february 1851 at the age of 53. she
left behind not just a sun and an unfinished
biography of percy shelley but also a creation
that had taken on a life of its own from its very
first production in 1823 frankenstein became a
staple of the theater with hundreds of versions
staged in multiple countries because of this
popularity it was eventually picked for adaptation
by the new film industry that arose in america
first in 1910 by thomas edison and then far more
famously by universal in 1931 and while boris
karloff's silent hulking monster maybe a million
miles away from the erudite creature of shelley's
tale the essence of her story that flicker
of sympathy we feel for the devil remained
unchanged today it's hard to imagine how fiction
would look without frankenstein so influential was
it that its effects can be seen almost everywhere
like bram stoker's dracula or the works of edgar
allan poe it's the bedrock of modern genre fiction
yet there was more to marry shelley than just this
one book as this video has hopefully shown she
was a woman who seemed to stand apart from her
own time not just as a literary pioneer but
as someone who tried her damnedest to live
on her own terms she didn't always succeed but
we've no doubt that had mary wollstonecraft
lived to see the woman her daughter grew up
to be she would have felt nothing but pride
so i really hope you found this video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching